LATEST DEVELOPMENT FROM ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND THE BIDEN
SYNDICATE.
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN VERY
TIGHT.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER
SENIOR COUNSELOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP,
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
ALONG THE FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
REINCE PRIEBUS.
KELLYANNE, START WITH YOU.
I WATCHED THIS INTERVIEW WITH
ZELENSKYY.
WATCHED IT CLOSELY.
I THOUGHT FOR THE FIRST TIME
PROBABLY IN OVER A AT LEAST
"60 MINUTES" DID A DECENT
SEGMENT BUT IT WAS ZELENSKYY'S
STRENGTH THAT MADE THIS SEGMENT
AND HIS RESOLVE.
THE FACT THAT HE DIDN'T GET ON A
PRIVATE JET, GET ASYLUM IN SOME
OTHER COUNTRY AND TAKE CASH IN
PRECIOUS METALS WITH HIM.
HE IS THEIR FIGHTING FOR HIS
COUNTRY.
THE ODDS ARE PRETTY HIGH THAT HE
MAY NOT MAKE IT THROUGH THIS.
BUT HE'S TELLING THE WORLD THIS
IS WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
PAY ATTENTION.
IT'S ABOUT GOOD AND EVIL AT THIS
POINT.
>> YES AND HE IS CALLING OUT
THESE FANCY TITLE COMMITTEES OF
THE U.N. AND NATO FOR NOT
HELPING.
REALLY LOOKING THE OTHER WAY IN
THE FACE OF GENOCIDE AND
TRAGEDY.
SEAN, IT SOUNDS SO FUN FOR US TO
RIDICULE JOE BIDEN AND HIS
INABILITY TO LEAD, TO SPEAK, TO
INSPIRE, TO HAVE A PLAN, SHOW
COMPASSION.
BUT GUESS WHAT.
IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
HE IS BACK IN THE BASEMENT.
HE JUST SPENT HIS 116TH DAY IN
DELAWARE AS PRESIDENT.
HE TOOK HIS 38TH TRIP THERE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF HE IS DOING
THAT WHILE ZELENSKYY IS FIGHTING
FOR THE SOVEREIGNTY AND SECURITY
OF THIS COUNTRY AND IS WALKING
AROUND WITH BORIS JOHNSON FROM
THE U.K.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT IN BIDEN WAS
NOT INSPIRED AND UNIFY THE
COUNTRY YET.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS SOMEHOW.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT MANY
AMERICANS ARE LOOKING FOR IN
SAYING WOW, THERE'S SOMEBODY
STANDING SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
WITH HIS OWN PEOPLE.
ZELENSKYY, IT'S QUITE BOLD FOR
THEM TO TELL 60 MINUTES IN FULL
VIEW FOR THE WORLD THAT HE IS
HEARKENING BACK TO HITLER AND
THE ATROCITIES OF WORLD WAR II
AND THAT HE SEES THE ANALOGIES
HERE.
SO I THINK IT'S A VERY STRONG
INTERVIEW.
I WISH WE HAD SOME KIND OF
RESPONSE FROM OUR OWN PRESIDENT.
HIS POLL NUMBERS COME
INTERNATIONALLY, DOMESTIC GREAT
I DON'T KNOW HOW LOW JOE CAN GO.
EVERY TIME HE -- I FIGURE HE'S
HIT ROCK BOTTOM BUT HE'S GOT A
NEW PROBLEM.
PEOPLE DRAW A DIRECT LINE
BETWEEN JOE'S FECKLESS AND
RECKLESS POLICIES AND ACTION AND
INACTION WITH THEIR OWN
SUFFERING.
65% AND THAT CBS PAUL SAY THEY
DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN HAS DONE
ENOUGH TO HELP WITH INFLATION
OR FUEL PRICES.
66% ARE BLAMING HIM AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE DRAWING A DIRECT LINE
BETWEEN THEIR OWN TEAMS AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
FOOD, FUEL, FORMULA FOR BABIES.
THESE ARE NOT LUXURIES.
THESE ARE EVERYDAY CONSUMABLES
AND NECESSITIES AND PEOPLE ARE
HAVING A VERY HARD TIME EATING
BASIC EXPENSES.
>> Sean: REINCE, I LOOK AT
THIS AND WE KNOW THAT PUTIN
DIDN'T DO THIS WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT.
HE DID IT WHEN JOE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AND OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT.
LOOKING AT BORIS JOHNSON.
WHY CAN'T THAT BE THE U.S.
PRESIDENT.
WHY DIDN'T PUTIN DO THIS UNDER
DONALD TRUMP?
WHY DID HE DO IT WITH BIDEN IN
OFFICE?
DO YOU AGREE THERE IS NO URGENCY
THAT'S NEEDED HERE?
>> I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU.
THE OTHER HALF ABOUT THE QUOTE
ABOUT PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH,
WEAKNESS ONLY INVITES
AGGRESSION.
THE WORLD IS NOT AFRAID OF
JOE BIDEN.
THINKING ABOUT WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING, WE ALL SIT ON
AIRPLANES.
EVERY WEEK.
SOMETIMES WE SAID BY
REPUBLICANS.
SOMETIMES YOU SIT BY DEMOCRATS.
I'VE NEVER HAD ANY CONVERSATION
WITH ANY DEMOCRAT THAT MAKES THE
ARGUMENT TO ME THAT JOE BIDEN IS
DOING A GREAT JOB AS PRESIDENT.
I'VE NEVER HAD A DEMOCRAT TELL
ME THAT.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE WHEN JOE BIDEN RAN, HE
RAN ON A SPECIFIC THEME.
THE THEME WAS, JOE BIDEN WAS THE
SAFE CHOICE FOR AMERICA.
EVERY THREE MONTHS, JOE BIDEN
GETS UP THERE AND SAYS AMERICA
IS BACK.
AMERICA IS BACK.
AS KELLYANNE JUST POINTED OUT,
IT'S SPRING BREAK TIME.
GAS IS UP 40%.
CAR RENTALS ARE UP 40%.
HAVE YOU RENTED A CAR LATELY?
AND PAID THE PRICE, IT'S
AMAZING.
YOU SHOP FOR A USED CAR BECAUSE
A LOT OF NEW CARS, YOU CAN'T GET
ANYMORE BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH CHIPS.
USED CARS ARE UP 40%.
>> Sean: GAS IS UP ALMOST
DOUBLE.
>> LIKE 40%.
40% IS THE NEW NORMAL.
A MILLION PEOPLE ARE GETTING
READY TO CROSS THE BORDER OVER
THE NEXT SIX WEEKS.
DHS, THE BIDEN DHS IS SAYING A
MILLION PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
CROSS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD A
COMPLETE PARTY CONTROL.
THE COUNTRY IS SPIRALING.
I THINK REPUBLICANS NOW HAVE A
REALLY -- A CHALLENGE TO
CAUSALLY POINT OUT WHERE WERE WE
WHEN WE HAD TOTAL CONTROL OVER
WASHINGTON, D.C.?
WE HAD RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT IF
YOU WERE A BLACK AMERICAN,
HISPANIC AMERICAN, WHITE
AMERICAN.
WAGES WERE UP.
AL QAEDA WAS DEAD.
NO FOREIGN POLICY DISASTERS.
NORTH KOREA DIDN'T DO A THING
FOR FOUR YEARS.
WE HAVE A REAL IMAGE AND PICTURE
THAT WE CAN PRESENT TO VOTERS
ACROSS AMERICA.
THEY ARE ALREADY THERE.
HE WAS A SAFE PICK.
NOTHING IS GOING WELL.
NOW IT'S UP TO REPUBLICANS TO
SHARE THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Sean: THEY KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE.
DONALD TRUMP WAS A STRONG
PRESIDENT.
YEAH, HE WAS STRONG WITH THE
PRESS.
MAYBE HE TWEETED OUT A THING OR
TWO THAT REALLY OFFENDED PEOPLE.
I'M NOT SO SURE IT DID.
WHEN HE WAS A STRONG, DECISIVE,
ENGAGED PRESIDENT.
THIS GUY, THIS IS A WEAK
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
WORLD WHEN